>> Brian: WELCOME BACK.
TONIGHT THE FBI CONFIRMING THE
RUSSIAN CYBER CRIME GANG CALLED
DARKSIDE APTLY NAMED WAS
COLONIAL PIPELINE THAT CARRIES
FUEL FROM TEXAS TO THE NORTHEAST
REMAINS SHUT DOWN AT THIS HOUR.
EXPERTS WARN IF THAT CONTINUES
THAT COULD PUSH GAS PRICES SKY
HIGH AND WIDESPREAD FUEL
SHORTAGES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
JOINING US HOUSE IS SENATOR TOM
COTTON.
SENATOR COTTON, HOW CONCERNED
ARE YOU ABOUT THIS?
>> BRIAN, I'M VERY CONCERNED.
I MEAN, FROM TWO DIFFERENT
ANGLES.
FIRST OFF, NO CYBER GANG IN
RUSSIAN COULD CONDUCT THIS KIND
OF ATTACK AGAINST AMERICAN PIECE
OF CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHOUT THE TACIT OR EXPLICIT
KNOWLEDGE OF VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
GOVERNMENT.
FIRST IS IT T. SHOWS JOE BIDEN'S
WEEK POLICY ON SAUDI ARABIA
CONSEQUENCES.
WHEN YOU GIVE AWAY THE STORE TO
RUSSIA.
WHEN YOU EXTEND THE NUCLEAR ARMS
TREATY THAT FAVORS OVER THE
UNITED STATES.
ALLOW RUSSIA TO BUILD A GAS
PIPELINE TO UNDER THE BALTIC SEA
AND INVITE HIM DESPITE ALL OF
THAT YOU INVITE THEM TO LAUNCH
ATTACKS IN THE U.S.
HIGHLIGHTS HOW BAD JOE BIDEN'S
ENERGY POLICY IS.
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU SHUT DOWN THE
KEYSTONE PIPELINE, YOU TAKE
FEDERAL LANDS OUT OF PRODUCTION
FOR OIL AND GAS.
OF COURSE YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
HIGHER PRICES AT THE GAS PUMP
AND IF YOU HAVE ANY KIND OF
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE GO DOWN
LIKE THIS, THAT'S ONLY GOING TO
BE HIGHER ENERGY PRICES FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE:  WHY NOT CYBER
TECHNOLOGY THAN THEY DO.
WHY SO WHY NOT GO SHOW THEM.
YOU HAVE GOT FIND A WAY TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE RIGHT
NOW OR THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN
TO YOU.
>> YEAH, BRIAN, THIS IS ANOTHER
EXAMPLE OF JOE BIDEN'S WEAK
POLICY TOWARDS RUSSIA, HE CALLS
VLADIMIR PUTIN A KILLER ONCE AND
HE ACTS LIKE IS HE A TOUGH GUY.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN BEATING
THEIR CHEST ABOUT RUSSIA THE
LAST FOUR YEARS.
SOMEBODY'S JOE BIDEN GOT IN
OFFICE THEY RETURNED TO THEIR
WEAK DOVISH ROOTS ONCE AGAIN.
THEY SHOULD IMMEDIATELY STOP
THAT PIPELINE THAT RUSSIA IS
BUILDING TOWARD GERMANY AND GO
ON OFFENSE IF THAT'S WHAT IT
TAKES TO GET RUSSIA TO PULL IN
ITS HORNS.
>> Brian: OTHER BIG STORY ON THE
DAILY MAIL THAT NOT MANY PEOPLE
ARE PAYING ATTENTION TO BUT WE
ARE.
154,000 EMAILS FROM HUNTER BIDEN
ON THAT LAPTOP.
103 TEXT MESSAGES, 2,000 PHOTOS.
ONE OF THOSE EMAILS STRUCK A
CORD BECAUSE IT TALKS ABOUT A
CHINESE SPY CHIEF OF CHINA WHO
HAS AN ASSISTANT WHO SAYS I'M
SENDING OPPOSITION RESEARCH TO
HELP JOE BIDEN'S 2020 ELECTION
BID AND IT FORWARDING PERSONAL
MESSAGES THAT'S A SIDE NOTE.
SHE ENCOURAGED HIM TO DRAW FROM
THE COMPANY'S ACCOUNT BEFORE
THEY WERE SHUT DOWN.
WAIT A SECOND, CHINA HELPING
PRESIDENT BIDEN WIN AN ELECTION?
WHERE HAVE I HEARD THAT BEFORE
WITH A DIFFERENT COUNTRY AND A
DIFFERENT CANDIDATE?
>> YEAH, BRIAN.
IT'S ASTONISHING WHAT CONTINUES
TO COME OUT ABOUT HUNTER BIDEN.
ONE REASON A LOT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT THIS
STORY BLUE MEDIA AND BIG TECH
CONTINUES TO ACT LIKE A FAY
LINKS OF BODY GUARDS.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID LAST
OCTOBER IT TWITTER AND FACEBOOK
IT HID STORIES ABOUT HUNTER
BIDEN'S SHADY DEALINGS.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
THIS AND UNDERSTAND WHY JOE
BIDEN WAS INVOLVED SO-CALLED SPY
CHIEF TO USE HIS OWN WORDS WITH
CHINA AND ALSO HOW HE IS ABLE TO
SO EASILY PUT WHAT APPEARS TO BE
AN AGENT OF THIS SO-CALLED SPY
CHIEF RIGHT IN HUNTER BIDEN'S
INNER CIRCUMSTANTIAL.
>> Brian: SENATOR.
-- INNER CIRCLE.>> Brian: YOU H
TO GET IVY LEAGUE EDUCATION.
I WAS GOING TO BUT I DIDN'T LIKE
THE CAMPUS.
IT DIDN'T SING MY NAME BUT YOU
WANT TO ATTACK THE ENDOWMENTS OF
THESE IVY LEAGUE SCHOOLS.
IT'S IN THE ZILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ALL TAX-FREE AND JUST SITS
THERE.
WHY?
>> YEAH, BRIAN.
I'M GOING TO INTRODUCE
LEGISLATION TOMORROW THAT I AM
INTRODUCING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TONIGHT ON YOUR SHOW
THAT'S GOING TO TAX ENDOWMENTS
OF THE BIGGEST,RICHEST AND
FRANKLY MOST LIBERAL
UNIVERSITIES IN AMERICA.
THEY HAVE TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS SITTING IN THEIR
ENDOWMENT.
THEY PAY ALMOST NOTHING IN
FEDERAL TAXES.
AND THEY CHARGE FULL FREIGHT TO
KIDS TO TAKE ZOOM CLASSES.
AND, BRIAN, THIS IS AT A TIME
WHEN THEIR ALSO ACTIVELY
INDOCTRINATING STUDENTS TO HATE
AMERICA, BELIEVE IT'S OPPRESSIVE
RACIST NATION.
IF JOE BIDEN WANTS THE RICH TO
PAY THEIR FAIR SHARE, I THINK WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON THESE LIBERAL
OUT-OF-TOUCH UNIVERSITIES PAYING
THEIR FAIR SHARES.  STEVE.
>> Brian: WE WILL SEE IF ANYBODY
ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE PUT THAT
TOGETHER.
IT MIGHT BE A STATEMENT RATHER
THAN A BILL THAT BECOMES A LAW.
SENATOR TOM COTTON THANKS SO
MUCH FOR JOINI